theme today is these are animal friends
that's right so this is a capuchin
monkey and we're gonna bring out his
friend right now who is completely
unlike it's an animal that if they
existed in the wild together would
probably eat him okay we're gonna put
this caracal right on the desk here you
might want to stand up this is it oh
yeah cuz it might attack me well you
know ba I pet it or I'm gonna give him a
pet there yeah this is a caracal it's a
caracal it's an African Wildcat and they
they hate each other in real life in
real life they probably would kill each
other oh he found the food yeah that's
Andy that's Andy's snack right there
yeah well let's do this yeah in the wild
caracals light like to eat birds but
they would eat a monkey and so luckily
in the wild these guys live in South
America and those guys live in Africa
but they were raised together and
they're like best buddies when you say
raised together like you got them an
apartment together what is it now okay
I'm actually really glad you said that
because as cute as these guys are both
it okay okay okay was that okay when he
was just trying to get he tried to mate
with the caracal he tried to give him a
hug that goes against God it was all
platonic monkey shall not lie down with
cat open a Bible I'm glad you said that
both of these animals aren't there any
can you put them on
the camera I look at him he just figured
out who I was and he's not happy if you
offer him food he'll be your friend let
me my pal way beyond how huh cs4 he all
right you to see that he thought he was
on Ellen and then he got a good look at
me he loves everybody I don't know what
it is about you know well he might fancy
Ville right there now but both of these
guys look like they would make great
pets but they don't usually I should not
own a big cat or a monkey this is so
crazy because I was about to get a
caracal and a monkey and try and have
them live together believe it or not a
lot of people do but these guys have an
especial zoo facility and have special
care and all that good why is he yelling
constantly at us that's because he's a
monkey that's monkeys do this is why
they don't make good pets they do this
24/7 so here buddy you're on it all
right
and I love is there a reason why this
caracal has these ears yeah
evolutionary reason for that I mean
there's big ears he'll ception the
confer cables yeah here their prey and
it also helps camouflage them in the
tall grass so I think we're gonna go on
to our next animals cuz these guys are
getting a little feisty here okay all
right let's move on to our next hunt
group of unlikely animal pals now this
one oh my lord now these guys are really
look how they carry the tortoise in
it looks like it looks like he Beach
he's been drinking all night and he just
loses an African Sal cotta tortoise and
this is a domestic goat these guys
actually live together and goats as we
all know like to hop on the back let's
see if he'll stay off that ever happened
they ever do that they this is what this
is what the goats do in their home so
you're saying you vent left to his own
devices the goat will get on top of
exactly goats love to be up high yeah
sort of a dominance thing and the goats
that live with this tortoise use him to
get up top and say I'm king of the hill
and there he goes off yeah he's trying
to he's trying to join the band right
now the thing that's really hey is like
I play the flute the thing that's really
ironic about this pairing is that why
domestic goats that have been released
into the wild have actually caused giant
tortoises in some parts of the world to
go extinct because they eat all the food
so don't tell him that because it will
ruin his friendship with this guy but
you know big problems and he could we
look at him now he's bummed out he's
stuck
he's over by the planter thinking it's
all over it's all over
but then when I met Andy on the street
in New York he was holding a goat like
this and then we got a divorce and she
left me oh yeah I mean it doesn't get
cuter than a baby girl yeah
you